so hello my name is a bill Dhaka I'm a
senior kernel developer at the Wolfram
research I've been working at Wolfram
research for around 10 years my title of
my talk is developing in the wolfram
compiler so this is the new welcome
compiler that was released in version 12
I'll be talking how to extend the
compiler and some neat applications that
were enabled by using that new compiler
so I'm gonna be talking about the
developing in the wolfram compiler my
name is Abdul I'm one of the developers
on the compiler project so I'm going to
describe the basic usage of the compiler
I'm gonna then describe a little bit of
the internals and how you know
developers after now developers are kind
of mainly us but we're gonna accept you
know we're gonna describe you know in
the next few releases we're gonna be
opening up the compiler to more
developers so that people can extend it
and we can use and that I'll show how
you one you can use the compiler to
develop multi-threaded code so there's
multiple talks on the compiler so
actually the numeric array just finished
Fahim is gonna talk about data feed you
know wolfen in finance platform you know
tomorrow
there's tom is gonna give a talk on the
Wolfram compiler tomorrow and then
Brenton is gonna talk about parsing the
Wolfram language versus dr. really the
compiler but it's related someone so
this is an overview of the compiler
syntax you have you know true you know
the traditional sort of function syntax
you know you but one thing you do is you
annotate all the input arguments with
the typed keyword so in this case I'm
saying that the arg1 type isn't in 64
the arc to type isn't in 64 and I wrap
everything with the function compile and
you know underneath the hood there's
some machinery to tell you you know that
tells the compiler that you know this
Plus is gonna be you know in in 64 to in
64 so one thing is the compiler right
now is more optimized more towards you
know like we want to build a solid code
but you know solid platform so that we
can generate very efficient code but as
well I'll show you a you know even the
current compiler is more generic than
the previous version of the compiler and
we've made a lot of
kind of interesting progress in the past
year so let me know the first thing you
know you probably if you've used the
compilers that or you know any other
compiler is that you know you you can
intermix compiled code with top level
code so in this case I'm compiling a
function that's doing a random walk now
I can compile it and then the results I
can use like visualization technology to
do the plot so in this case you know I I
you know I'm using I'm compiling kind of
the computationally heavy part of the
code and then the other parts I can just
leverage pre-existing techniques
pre-existing you know code and that's
kind of the designs like we want to have
a seamless integration between things
that are you know compiled them may be
you know there's some restrictions and
the rest of the code which has you know
practically in our restrictions the
other thing is you know there are some
cases where you want to have uncompelled
code within compiled code so let's say
you know there's some codes which it
makes no sense to compile so something
like file IO or you know in this case
this is getting some entity so in this
case we introduced in version twelve
this concept of a kernel function so a
kernel function takes a function and a
type and then evaluates that that kernel
function within the evaluator so in this
case what I'm doing is I'm getting the
you know I'm giving it a name and then
I'm getting the mass of the planet
called with that name so that and then
I'm you know so this is the code that is
run within Mathematica the interpreter
but the rest is
she run in the compare the rest is
composed so in you know M times a is is
a compiled function now you can build
more complicated examples but this is a
you know simple thing so in this case
you know I'm intermixing even within
compiled code I'm intermixing
uncompelled with compiled you know
there's some sort of layer so you can
intermix on the outside or on the
outside of compiled or in the inside of
compiled feel free to ask any questions
it's like an hour presentation yeah well
you know user error I mean it will it
will tell you you know the types are
unexpected it would throw an exception
and I wouldn't evaluate in uncompelled
code right right yeah so right so here's
here's an example so in this case this
quantity magnitude or entity is giving
you an arbitrary precision float so the
way around that I did was I said set
precision to machine precision but let's
say I didn't do that and in fact I was
not doing that and I evaluate this now
it's a bit hard to read but it says a
compiled compiled code runtime error
occurred reverting to uncompelled you
know evaluation so is still giving you
correct results it's just this real 64
was not satisfied at runtime because the
result was not a real 64 it was an
arbitrary precision arithmetic
right
also these examples are meant to fit on
the screen there's you know you and you
know you'd have more complicated
programs and you obviously need better
you know you need more informative
errors like Tom was saying for that so
here's another sort of feature of
compiled code and that's it's their
affordable so here is a fairly
complicated way of writing an infinite
loop and and the reason is you know you
know people probably write these things
I mean yeah and then they they they fix
them and then but you know I can I can
say okay function compile and then a
while loop and this index is never what
is this index is never like you know
even errs you know but I could say okay
evaluate this what with a time
constraint of 0.5 seconds and if you
know this code takes more than 0.5
seconds so it aborts so that's kind of
another features that you can abort
these evaluations or you know if I do
just doing that sorry so if I have you
know this thing is evaluating infinitely
and if I do you know command dot or you
know on Windows it's control dot or
something you know you would get aborted
the other kind of interesting feature
and this is something that I had trouble
with the old compiler is that compile
these compiled functions are now
composable which means that can
construct a function and then I can pass
that as an argument to another kind of
compiled function so in this case I'm
defining a mapper function which is you
know just does eight plus two and I'm
gonna define a my own map function which
essentially just for every element of
the list it's gonna apply that input
it's going to take an F and then input
list and it for every element of that of
that list is going to just apply F to it
and you're just going to return some
result so then I can essentially apply I
can call that my mapper function with
range of ten and I would get that result
so I can build the more complicated
programs or I can pass in functions
around or I can return functions from
compiled functions and so on so which
means you can you know express more
complicated programs and you don't have
to have one big piece of block of code
that contains all your all your programs
the other interesting thing is that
compiled code support strings so you
know you know the bytecode compiler only
supported you know real complex boolean
and integer and the list versions of all
of those but the new compiler supports
strings so this thing just says you know
give me the count the number of letters
in in a string it only works for you
know lowercase letters but you know I
can then say okay give me the letter
count of the Declaration of Independence
so it has the letter counts for a you
know through Z and then the last one is
the other you know if something is not a
lowercase letter it just puts it over
there
now one byproduct of that is also that
you can do print you know I can do print
of res and you know evaluate that and it
would you know do a printing of the the
list so in this case it's kind of more
you know you know it's printing that
it's a packed array ranked one packed
array of length 27 and it has that
content or I could do you know you know
sort of you know print of anything or
even because of the integration with the
kernel you can even do echo so that's so
the other thing is that compiled code
supports expression so this is you know
you could do arithmetic on expressions
so symbolic kind of evaluation so in
this case I have a function that takes
two expressions a and B and and B are
you know could be any Wolfram expression
so I can put a graphics disk or
something you know M times the disk you
know so this this is
compiled but you know you know you can
use this or so and actually the
application of this might become more
relevant in went on shows the data
structure and and sort of iterator cuz
yeah so this in this case you could
actually go around the evaluator so you
can so in the Mathematica kernel each
you know let's say plus is there there's
a function a C function called you know
plus that the evaluator eventually
reaches into but through this mechanism
oh this is a time so you know eventually
it would reach some C times that works
with arbitrary expression so this thing
is just going around the evaluator and
just calling that times directly so
there is some speed benefit now
obviously it's not the right
right and probably like four simple
things it won't be it won't be faster
but there are cases where you actually
want to use this and if you did not have
even if it's slower even if it's ten
times slower
you know if the surrounding code is a
thousand times faster but this is the
blocking thing then you would want you
know even you know even if it's or you'd
want that sort of you know feature
that's that's kind of the the answers
you know there are features that are
would enable other speed ups you know
well I I don't know what that right
right I mean I'll show some speed ups
results in fact this slide will show
something so the other thing is in
version twelve definitely in 12.1
there's these numeric arrays and numeric
arrays are essentially generalization of
these pack trees so arrays that work on
all the C scalar data types like int 8
and unsigned int 32 and real 32 things
like that so in this case you know so
the compiler knows about these things so
you can just say I have a list that's a
numeric array of real 64 and then I can
define a moving average so a moving
average you know you take in this case
it's just looks at three elements is
just a compliment you know this is just
a service sort of a convolution type of
thing but it's looking at three elements
is handling the case of you know is it
at the beginning or the end
and I could do the evaluation and I get
the correct results so I can just pass
in a numeric array range of 10 of real
64 I would get that result now you know
we're still adding support for these
numeric array for a bunch of functions
but moving average is not one of them so
you know you get an error so you'd have
to use these packed arrays or you know
yeah or you know other or their service
code but you know if you do the
comparison so the top one is you know
using the native moving average now the
moving average is a lot more generic you
know it takes a lot of you know a lot of
parameters and a lot of function in this
case I'm just having a specialized
version but the top one is showing you
know it takes a point one seconds for
these 10,000 elements and my code is
taking you know 0.03 seconds and I can
make a plot of the results so I can just
evaluate this over a million elements
for the both the top-level moving
average and my implementation of moving
average and I can make a plot and you
know this is like a log this is a log
plot so the blue line is the built-in
one and the yellow line is is the
compiled one and you know this is like
10 to the minus 6 and this is 10 you
know like 2 times 10 to the minus 5 so
it's a log plus so this you know at this
point it's taking you know like let's
say 10 to the minus 4 but this one is
taking you know 0.01
you know seconds so so there's like you
know a huge speed up you know 100 you
know 200,000 X sort of gross so take
that with
a grain of salt because I'm building a
specialized piece of codes and I'm
comparing to a more general case but
let's say I built I wrote optimized C
code and I compare that to handwritten
compiled code so this is you know the
red ones are see the blue ones are
compiler and this is from a few months
ago so we were actually better and the
other sort of scenarios but I wrote
manual but for example and we're about
the same as you know handwritten
optimized C code
you know same thing for a Gaussian
filter you know if you actually compare
I have to ask you know like I wrote a C
version that's using mkl and I compared
it to our version and we're faster than
the mkl you know both are using mkl is
just you know we're specializing you
know we have more flags or something for
the mkl you know histogram is is the
same sort of speed-up so this is the
sort of speed-up that if you were to
write this is the kind of the target
speed up your you're comparing as see
you're not comparing relate to top level
so how we achieve that so internally we
go through them the compilers up there's
a complicated thing but we go through a
multi stage pipeline to make it more
manageable and understandable so we take
this Wolfram expressions or abstract
syntax trees and we do some
transformations to make it simpler we
call that we call that the sugar ASD so
there's you know it's a subset of the
expressions then we go to this
intermediate representation so this is
something like assembly but it's system
agnostic and it's untyped so we have
this on type I R then we do some type
inference so we try and fill out what
the types are for that I R then we do we
get this type IR and then we generate an
executable and there's a lot of
optimizations that are happening at
every stage of this sort of process so
let me kind of give you an overview of
this so let's say I have a function and
this is the running sort of function so
I'm going to be using so I have a I mean
I get an N and then I do a do loop that
just increments up to N and I return the
result so it's kind of not not
interesting function but it produces you
know it's a proxy so the first thing
that we're gonna do is we're gonna do
expression analysis and transforms and
what you're gonna get out of this
function is a new whether you're gonna
get out of this expression is a new
expression that has the same it is still
a valid mathematical expression but it
you know it replaced the do loop with a
while loop you know it did some
optimizations like you know the the
increments became a plus and and it's
doing like I was saying I know this
number is a will never overflow so I
could do arithmetic in a certain mode
and things like that so this is a sort
of operations that you know when we take
a user input we translate it into this
sort of form and we annotate you know
properties on that sort of expression so
that you know so that we are able to
kind of correlate back to the original
input form then we take that sort of
expression and we go through this what
we call lower you know lower form IR or
you know this untyped IR and what you
get is again I you get a data structure
but I'm just presenting it as a textual
form where every node you know you get a
graph there every node
is a linear sequence of instructions and
there's edges if there's like jumps so
if conditions and loops they become
jumps into other sort of linear
execution instructions this is not
something that people want to read
they're you know essentially this is
something that the compiler developers
are interested in but not really for the
general public
now we then do optimizations and if you
notice this this complicated well this
is not super complicated but there's a
lot of instructions here and we compress
that or we optimize that into this sort
of program and this is the minimal
program that you need to execute the
code correctly and then finally we use
you know backends such as LLVM to
generate more system specific
intermediate representations and this
again is a much lower level than our
Wolfram I R but it's closer to the the
final assembly and then finally we
generate assembly code this is x86
assembly that performs the operations
and this becomes you know if you just I
had to cut this but this becomes quite
long quite quickly if you have you know
complicated I mean even even like you
know five nested loop like you know just
like three nested loops and you know
when you when you're looking at like
these data structures that you know tom
is doing is just like you know 20 pages
of thing and it just tells you you know
and you know you have to debug eight or
you know stuff like that
but but because we have a pipeline sort
of algorithm every every sort of stage
we can actually inspect what's exactly
happening and we can isolate that you
know so let's say if an if something is
deleted or something
they're corrupted we were able to to
figure out why it happens we also have
like some sanity checks internally for
the compiler developers so that you know
you don't delete a function that's
actually called and things like that so
we have an internal linter so this is
kind of the high level workflow of the
compiler and you can add extra things
extra components in at each level but
I'm gonna talk about two high level more
high level things that you can actually
add into the into the compiler and
that's you can extend the type
environment so let's say I want a you
know some complete you know some some
special function that's not in the the
compiler you can add that or you can say
oh you know my new primitive is just a
syntactic sugar for something a bit more
basic so you know something like up to
is a syntax trigger for something like
you know if the length is less than you
know and do something otherwise do
something else or nothing is another
example it just deletes the thing so and
this is very low-level syntax it's
probably not going to be exposed this
way but I can show you how how you could
do it so let's say I want to add a new
type so I'm not happy with you know
whatever types I don't you know I don't
care about in 64 I want in in 64 module
24 so I can do operations on that type
so I can say okay I'm going to define
this type in 64 or I'm going to define a
function that I'm going to find a binary
function is it takes two in 64 and
returns in 64 and I'm going to define
the plus and times on that now actual
plus addition
I'm just gonna do it in in 64 and then
I'm gonna do the mod and then I'm gonna
cast back so this is like you know C
type of casts that you could do to kind
of you know tell this to use the integer
plus but then I'm going to define sort
of a a wrapper around that and then I'm
going to define that I have a new
sorry why did this not
a second
fact
Hey
okay so I'm gonna define a new type
called in 64 modulo 24 and I'm gonna
define new functions plus that's going
to call my plus function that I defined
previously and then times and then I can
essentially write you know eight times B
plus B you know plus a times B you know
some some expression and I can then
generate code from that so this is the
you know I can generate a program from
that this but it defined you know when
it goes to the the operations it's
calling this my times in 64 module in 64
and that's defined as you know I call to
the run time function that does a binary
plus and then it's doing a sort of as
well actually it's a binary times and
then it's doing a month but essentially
I can define kind of arbitrary functions
on that now to execute this I need to
tell the you know the code generator to
the generousity assembly
what does in 64 means but I'm not gonna
do that in this case right and then
other than adding types you can also add
functions so I have a function here
which is a Euclidean distance so it
takes you know XCore X&Y coordinates and
these x and y coordinates are different
for any type so this is a this is saying
for any type a this function takes you
know forays and returns an a and then
you know I can just define that I can
then call I can then add a function
called my distance which has that you
know has that implementation and then I
can define like a nearest type of
function so this nearest function is
just saying
I'm gonna get a point and a point cloud
and I'm just gonna go through all the
elements and find it the smallest the
point with the smallest distance so I
can just kind of do that and get the
results so right so so I get the results
that's yep so you know you can
essentially add your own your own
function and extend the compiler if
something is not supported and this is
how we actually develop the compiler so
we you know we we retry examples there's
some things that are not supported we
add an implementation but we add
everything in top level in in the
Wolfram language so you can also add
functions that reference external
libraries so I think Fahim is gonna show
a more complicated example of that but
in here I have a function that I want to
call the Lib C sign on it so you know so
but you know you can have a function
that you can implement something like
library link on top of this you know you
can have a you know refer to an external
function that has such and such a name
and you know you provided the name and
the type and then you can just call it
so this is calling the you know sine
function from Lib C now the the other
stuff is you know you can go even
further so you know you've already
written in to see well what happens if I
want to write assembly so so I'm not I'm
not going to show how exactly you write
that but this is a CPU ID instruction in
assembly that is implemented and and
what this thing allows you to do is get
some parameters from the CPU so for
example in here I'm saying does this
support SSC 3
these vector instructions version three
on this machine
and you can kind of you know in here you
can see that it's calling some assembly
and these are the assembly instructions
that is calling so it's embedding
assembly in sort of the low level
implementation so you can't you're
actually intermixing assembly with
Mathematica you know so you can go from
expressions down to assembly right so
the other way of extending the compiler
is by adding macros so this is you know
if you have a function that's just
syntax sugar for something a bit more
primitive than you could do that and
there's a lot of functions that are
essentially can be decomposed into wire
loops or you know variations of that so
here I have a function which I want to
define horner form for it
so horner form is not known to the
compiler and you you know so it's just
saying horner form and you know it has
the power and things like that
now one thing you could notice is that
there's an X X X to the power of two and
there's already a macro in the language
that says X to the X to the power of two
or anything to the power of two is just
you multiply the thing twice you know do
you multiply the thing by itself so in
here I have an X and then I sort of
multiplied that now I can say I'm gonna
register this horner form now for the
sake of demonstration I'm just gonna
take a special case of horner form I'm
not going to show you know the recursive
definition
it matches exactly what I have in the
previous slide in the previous example
but you know I'm just gonna take the
horner form and you can specify the
patterns
that you know that that you want to
capture so I have a you know coefficient
third coefficient you know to the power
of three and I'm just going to expand
that to the Horner form and now Horner
form is known to the companion well it's
not known to the compilers known you it
can accept to the you know Horner form
is acceptable to the compiler so it
let's see so it D sugared that function
into you know this function so it's 2
plus 7 times X times you know some some
other things I think that parentheses
are not showing but they're there so
that's why I was doing this to print but
you know you have this this module times
this sort of expression so there's other
new features that we're going to be
adding or you know we we want to add to
the compiler and to the language in
general and one is data structures so
see Tom's talk tomorrow
and there's also parallel evaluation so
I'm going to talk about parallel
evaluation in the next you know a few
minutes so what you want to write in
parallel about so Mathematica already
has a thing called you know you know
paralyzed parallel map yep sure yeah
you can use patterns I mean it's a
implementation of the pattern matching
it's not used it's not the kernel
pattern matching but yeah right pattern
test works condition works so those two
cases you know seek blank sequence you
know yet flat order list that's not
supported but you know default value I
mean I think I think 90% you know of the
cases you know if there's a ways around
you know if you want order lists or
flatten you might have to go into a more
manual process you know but you could do
the transformation just not using the
macro system you could do ast sort of
transformations so so in in in you know
I don't know since you know before I
joined so you know there was already a
parallel evaluation system so you
essentially say I have a function I want
to paralyze the map function and I would
work and it also this thing worked on
not only multiple multiple processors
but it was it also works on multiple
machines so if I have a cluster of
machines that can then say farm out this
you know function to a bunch of machines
and do the evaluation but one of the
problems is it uses multiple processes
to do the evaluation rather than
multiple threads and what that means is
well that that's something that you know
that that's a you know paralyzed uses
multiple processes but also there's a
there's another thing which is users are
not able to write multiple threaded code
so people want to write regardless of
powell map or parallel
people want to say launch this thread or
launch this task split this you know in
parallel or in the background and then
join that later and things like that so
people cannot write that in top level
but you could do that in the compiler so
in in current Mathematica the way
parallel evaluation works is that and
this is not the implementation this is
what I think the implementation is so
you know if I do parallel map what it
does is it would launch a bunch of
kernels it would then distribute the
definition of that function the input
function into to all the kernels it
would then partition the data into the
number of kernels that were launched it
would submit a you know the program with
that chunk data into all the sort of sub
kernels you would wait for all the jobs
to complete and then we just return you
the results so pictorially you know you
take a list you part you know you
evaluate parts of that list on a bunch
of kernels and then you wait and then
you you you you know you get the result
now there's nothing wrong with this in
fact that's like how parallel evaluation
works in general but the problem is that
it's doing this in multiple processes
and and it you know it has to copy data
it cannot work on things in place and
things like that so what what in
practice happens is that these sort of
you know submitting jobs and and waiting
getting you know aggregating results
becomes a huge bottleneck so you cannot
work in place you cannot share that list
or give something a view of of the input
array so what we want is to essentially
have same idea just you know I want to
have the list to be you know shared
between between the two and the results
can just all right into the same
location rather than you
copying data from multiple processes so
it's relatively trivial to write this as
an ASC transformation so it's not super
complicated I mean fits on the screen
but what you could do is just say okay
I'm gonna just do the same operation but
instead of launching kernels I'm gonna
launch some threads I'm then gonna
create a view of that array so what a
view is essentially it's a window of the
array so it's a you know in this case
it's like a read-only kind of it's a
read-only like you know essentially you
you you have the underline it's same
underlying data but your indices are
essentially shifted by you know a
certain position so you know let's say I
have a let's say I do a a partition here
Shammi sort of so if I do a partition I
want a view might be same underlying
data but the index one starts over here
so this is these data are shared except
the when I index into this one just
points to this and then one in here
points to that so this is like a view
partition and there's a bunch of
languages that have this sort of feature
but I can create that so that you know I
don't incur data copy sort of overhead
and then I can essentially say submit a
new function that feeds in that list
view into each into each thread and then
I can join the threads and then return
the output and what that means is I have
the same sort of figure it should be an
arrow over here but it's the same figure
but now I'm using instead of multiple
processes I'm using multiple threads and
the all the data is shared so in here
have a shared view of that list and I
don't do any extra mem copy or any any
sort of operation now we can implement
that so in this case this is a dummy
example that just does nothing useful
other than you know it's it's it does
some work this doesn't require
right so this is right this is not
distributed right well but ray-ray on
different machines that's kind of what
you sow so this is a function that just
there's a loop in the middle and then I
have a parallel do that you know it just
iterates a thousand times and I'm using
a parallel do instead of a do in here I
could also do paralyze do now if I
launch my sure so I need to I need this
thing right so right now is there a way
to clear this
okay clear but you know I'm sort of idle
these are the four different cores I
have four cores and you know there's
more there's hyper-threading but you
know I disabled those but it's not using
all four cores right now now if I do the
parallel evaluate kind of see it take
but if I increase that problem is
increasing that means the other parts
are become slower so I made it ten times
slower but it's doing you can kind of
see it you know did any you know it did
it did use multiple threads in here so
see that so let's let's kind of go back
and then compare am I actually doing
parallel sequential so I have the same
code except instead of a peril do I just
put a do and then I can evaluate that
function and get the parallel timing so
before it was 0.8 seconds now it's one
you know the sequential is one point
eight five now if you do the parallel do
function so just without function so I'm
just calling the parallel func
peril func without this function compile
it takes about 73 seconds so but if I
essentially decrease the you know
originally I have a thousand if I
decrease it to 100 because of we're not
gonna wait a minute it takes you know
4.5 seconds to do the traditional way of
of performing evaluation you know so you
know you're getting again you know
and take this with a grain of salt but
you know you're getting you know from 73
to you know a hundred x speed up a a
type of type of benefit so I think
that's pretty much it unless there's any
questions yeah sure
yes but nummy is its yeah so definitely
we're constantly expanding
yeah well it's it's saying I mean I can
show you the implantation Isis it's
right you don't need to link the library
right so this is so so an example is the
parallel stuff is using OpenMP they open
in p runtime and if you look at you know
some of these are a bit hairy but let me
see if I can find a simple definition so
you know this this thing so I'm giving
it a pretty name called open MP RTL
begin but underneath yeah you give it
you tell it what's the external function
name and what are the types but if and
and if the function is already in the
kernel open MP is already in there you
don't have to tell the external library
but if it's not you tell it oh you know
load the library from such-and-such
location and that's kind of like how
some some of those sort of so so for
example printf you
right right printf is is complicated so
but you want to call it because it's you
know you can kind of say it's threat
safe or you know some sort of thing but
so so it's sometimes useful to print
stuff to debug file I own assembly well
also no no that's not the problem the
problem is there is you need to
instantiate them how do you instantiate
them I mean what which functions first
of all and though okay well vector is
not a it's a data structure you can
write a wrapper around this C wrapper
and then export it so I think we need to
go but out please